welcome to the man of recaps this is the
complete marvel recap up to doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
now everything through avengers end game
is ancient history at this point and
covered in my previous recap so watch
those if you need it this new saga
begins with spider-man far from home the
world is dealing with the after effects
of the blip when thanos snapped away
half the population then five years
later the avengers snapped him back with
iron man dead the world is wondering who
will be the next big hero it might be
peter parker spider-man but for now he
just wants to be a normal teenager goes
on a school field trip to europe and
tries to pursue his new crush mj but
when a water monster attacks a new hero
flies in called mysterio turns out
mysterio is a hero from a parallel earth
and together he and spider-man fight
these elementals now tony stark left
peter the edith glasses which control
the whole arsenal of stark technology
but now mysterio is a great hero and an
adult so peter passes glasses to him but
wait what's this the whole bar was a
hologram this was all a con they're a
group of disgruntled former stark
employees are using advanced hologram
technology to create the fake world's
next best hero but to make it believable
the damage they cause is real pretty
soon peter figures it out but it's hard
to fight mysterio when you can't see him
but luckily one of his powers is the
spider sense the peter tingle that lets
him sense danger so he takes out these
drones mysterio accidentally shoots
himself looks like he's dead for real so
the day is saved and peter gets the girl
but then there's a report from the jay
jonah jameson where mysterio's team
leaked an edited video making spider-man
have to be the bad guy and worse they
leaked his real identity to the world
also the nick fury in this movie turns
out was actually a scroll shapeshifter
remember from captain marvel they're
good guys they were covering for fury
while he's off on a secret mission in
space so watch out for that next up is
the first disney plus series wand
division remember wanda maximoff and
vision had a romance going but
unfortunately he was killed in infinity
war but now the two of them are living
in an old school tv sitcom with no
explanation but sometimes things get
trippy and weird what is going on here
we need our new secret agency sword
which is basically like shield in space
we follow agent monica rambo yes the
little girl from captain marvel she
teams up with fbi agent jimmy wu from
ant-man and the wasp and darcy the
intern from thor long story short they
figure out wandas put a hex around this
town she was so sad over vision's death
she lost control of her powers and
turned this whole town into sitcomsville
where she envisioned could have a family
and live happily ever after
unfortunately though she's accidentally
taken this whole town hostage but one of
the side characters the neighbor agnes
is actually the witch agatha harkness
here to steal wanda's powers and she
reveals that one is not just a normal
witch she's a legendary being called the
scarlet witch so watch out for that
meanwhile bad government guy i tried to
weaponize original vision's body but tv
vision talks him out of it and he flies
off and monica rambo travels through the
hex which somehow gives her unspecified
superpowers and the scrolls come to
recruit her for nick fury space mission
so wanda and agatha have their final
witch fight where wanda wins by
embracing the full power of the scarlet
witch complete with a new bomb ass
outfit one to leave zagatha there but
turns her back into her character agnes
and she takes down the hex to free the
town unfortunately losing her kids who
were fake but real to her and also loses
this version of vision who only existed
inside here but later as she's learning
more about her magic powers she hears
her son's calling out to her whoa next
up is the falcon and the winter soldier
remember in endgame old steve rogers
passed the mantle of captain america to
his friend the falcon sam wilson but
sam's like look no one can live up to
that legacy we should retire the shield
but immediately the government names a
new captain america this random
douchebag meanwhile sam teams up with
his bickering buddy bucky barnes the
winter soldier to take down a new group
of super soldiers the flagsmashers and
they need help from a villain zemo from
civil war we didn't get to know him much
in civil war but turns out he's super
rich and kind of a hilarious guy and a
great dancer he takes them to the crime
city of madrapore where they also
recruit sharon carter who's also on the
run after civil war now the flag
smashers are kind of good guys trying to
help people displaced by the blip but
they do blow people up so not that good
the new captain america john walker
tries to fight him but they got super
strength they destroyed all the serum
except for one so he takes it and now
he's a full-on super soldier but when
they kill his friend he gets real mad
and oh no kills one of them he defiles
the shield and now it's trending on tick
tock so sam and bucky fight him to get
the shield back and with a new wakandan
super suit sam wilson is the new captain
america he does not have super strength
but he can fly so fair trade off long
story short he saves the day by giving
some senators a stern talking to sam and
bucky become best friends for real zemo
goes back to prison and sharon carter
gets her part in but turns out she is
the mysterious leader of madrapore the
power broker so she's kind of a villain
now and john walker is approached by
julia louise dreyfuss playing a shady
spy type character val she puts him in a
cool new black suit and renames him the
us agent and it seems like she's putting
together a team of heroes that aren't
afraid to kill people next up in
intended release order is black widow
yes natasha romanov the black widow
finally gets her own solo movie of
course she's dead now having tragically
sacrificed herself in endgame this movie
takes place right after civil war when
she was on the run where she has to take
down the new floating red room where
they're training a new group of black
widow assassins including one called
taskmaster who's been trained in the
fighting styles of all the avengers long
story short she blows it up and on
brainwashes them all the important thing
from this movie is that natasha
reconnects with her sister yelena she
was a black widow too and is just as
badass as natasha it seems like she
might take up her sister's mantle become
the new gen z black widow for now though
it's val who comes to recruit her too
next up it's loki season one remember
during endgames time heist they
accidentally knocked the space stone to
loki he was all set to resume his plans
for world domination but then some
random people came out of a portal and
put him under arrest they work for the
tva the time variance authority they
monitor all of time and keep people from
stepping off their pre-ordained
destinies this prevents a multiverse
from emerging keeps it all a nice tight
single timeline this loki's off his
rails they're gonna prune him but one
agent steps in it's owen wilson has
agent mobius instead he recruits this
loki to help track down another more
evil loki but turns out it's not an evil
loki it's a girl loki whose name is
sylvie loki decides to join her and at
first they butt heads but eventually
become real close but soon they're
captured by the tva and brought before
the time keepers they managed to kill
him but they were just robots wizard of
oz style who's the man behind the
curtain before they find out loki gets
pruned but turns out that doesn't kill
him it sends him to the end of time
where a whole bunch of loki variants are
hanging out including one that's
inexplicably an alligator long story
short loki showed mobius the tva was
lying to him and these two became best
friends then loki and sylvie go to find
out who's really pulling the strings and
turns out it is just some guy he doesn't
give his name here but we know it's kang
and he's a human scientist from future
earth who discovered the multiverse and
met up with all his other selves but
some of his other selves wanted to
conquer the multiverse and so it started
a multiversal war so this one created
the tva whose real purpose was to
prevent other kings from emerging he's
bored now though and he's willing to put
sylvian loki in charge by the way these
two fell in love but still be kicks loki
away cause she wants to stab this guy
and burn the whole thing down he's like
well guess you'll meet new versions of
me soon because without the tva new
timelines start branching and the
multiverse is here next up is what if
season one it's an awesome animated show
that explores this new multiverse as
narrated by the watcher who has taken a
vow not to interfere it explores cool
alternate timelines like what if instead
of steve rogers we got captain peggy
carter potentially relevant to
multiverse of madness is the
zombiepocalypse episode where zombie
wanda was terrifying but most important
is the doctor strange episode which asks
what if his love interest christine died
in the car crash steven still becomes
the sorcerer supreme but he tries to use
the time stone to save her but it's a
fixed point in time no matter what he
does she always dies but this doctor
strange decides he just needs more power
and so he starts absorbing mystical
beasts which does give him incredible
cosmic power but wrecks havoc on the
complexion in the end he does save
christine but it destroys his entire
universe leaving him alone to reflect on
his mistakes for eternity the season 1
finale asked what if ultron won long
story short he got the infinity stones
destroyed the whole universe and became
so strong he threatened the whole
multiverse so the watcher had to break
his vow recruited his favorite alternate
heroes into the guardians of the
multiverse eventually they won and
locked this ultron in a pocket dimension
watched over by a repentant evil doctor
strange next up is chongqi and the
legend of the ten rings meetshong a nice
normal guy living in san francisco with
his best friend katie but when he's
attacked by some goons on the bus turns
out he's not so normal he's a kung fu
master turns out his father was an
ancient chinese warlord who conquered
the world with the power of the ten
rings mysterious artifacts which made
him a video game character he created
the ten rings league of assassins to
manipulate the world from the shadows
his whole life he trained shong to be an
assassin too but shang's a good guy so
he ran away first they travel to an
underground fighting ring with
super-powered people they find chong's
sister who's a kung fu master too but
soon their dad picks them up and takes
them to a secret ninja compound by the
way if the ten rings sounds familiar it
was from iron man 3. can't remember the
mandarin who ended up being a fake decoy
villain but xiang's dad didn't
appreciate him using his name so in his
dungeon he has actor trevor slattery
long story short they travel to the
mystical village of tallow where pokemon
are real they guard the prison of the
ancient demon who's tricked their father
into opening it and boom demon lord out
evil dad realizes he's made a huge
mistake and sacrifices himself to save
shang and passes the 10 rings to him and
now the guardian of tallow is a dragon
so shong's got 10 rings he's riding a
dragon katie's there too and saves the
day by hitting this thing with an arrow
then chauncey with the ten ring super
punch blows this thing up his sister
takes over the ten rings organization
and it's unclear if it's still evil or
not but as for the ten rings themselves
no one knows what they are but when
shang put them on it sent out a beacon
so watch out for that next up is
eternals meet the eternals a group of
super space people who came to earth in
ancient times in fact they inspired a
lot of cool legends like athena and
gilgamesh they were sent here with one
job to fight the deviants these like you
know dinosaur monsters and they killed
the last deviant like a thousand years
ago so now in modern times they're just
kind of chilling we follow cersei who is
hilariously dating jon snow but when a
deviant shows up her eternal
ex-boyfriend flies in and i kid you not
it's rob stark they track down the rest
of the gang like kingo who's a bollywood
movie star and films a documentary about
the eternals it's an eternal family
reunion and they get a call from their
boss the giant celestial arsham he
explains their real job was to prepare
earth for the birth of a new celestial
which would unfortunately destroy the
planet most of the eternals have built
lives here and are not gonna let that
happen but icarus is like yo it's our
job so he goes full homelander on him
and it's a big eternals fight in the end
the emergence is starting so it's up to
cersei to stop it by using her power to
turn this whole thing
into marble icarus feels real bad now so
he eats himself into the sun so the day
is saved until their celestial boss
shows up which has got to be terrifying
if you're a normal person he takes the
eternals with him like we're gonna have
a talk and maybe i'll be back to destroy
the earth later meanwhile some of the
gang is out in space looking for other
eternals and they find one called star
fox also jon snow has a family heirloom
that's a magic sword and someone's
talking to him so watch out for that
next up is hawkeye meet kate bishop the
self-described greatest archer in the
world she comes from a wealthy new york
family and starts unraveling a mystery
that takes her to a secret auction one
of the items is the ronin suit that
hawkeye wore when he was a vigilante
during the blip and once the bad guys
bust in kate puts the suit on to fight
him hawkeye clint barton is actually in
new york with his kids for christmas
watching the new avengers musical when
he sees someone's wearing his suit he
tracks kate down who is super excited to
meet your favorite avenger she basically
forces him to take her as a sidekick and
these two do some aero adventures
together the leader of the gang they're
fighting is echo who is deaf and has a
prosthetic leg but is a huge badass
she's out for vengeance because ronin
killed her father also here for
vengeance is yelena someone just put out
a hit on hawkeye and val told her that
he killed her sister kate and elena eat
macaroni and become new best friends and
elena tells kate that the person who
ordered the hit was kate's mom who turns
out works for the big crime boss of new
york you know who that is it's kingpin
yes wilson fisk from the netflix
daredevil show now officially part of
the mcu so our archers team up to take
him down and save christmas he's a
really tough guy though very difficult
to kill kate even blows him up but he
still walks that off but turns out he's
the uncle of echo who just found out he
had her father killed and she shoots him
but he'll probably walk that off too so
kate bishop and clint barton saved
christmas and now she's ready to become
the new hawkeye and now it's spider-man
no way home after mysterio leaked his
identity peter parker finds himself in
some legal trouble so he needs a really
good lawyer and this is matt murdock yes
the daredevil from the netflix show he's
just here for a nice little cameo to
tease you that yeah daredevil's coming
back but now peter's life is turned
upside down so he goes to visit his
wizard friend doctor strange it's like
yeah bro i'll cast a spell to make the
world forget your spider-man but peter
keeps adding exceptions like aunt may
ned and mj and so the spell's unstable
and wow what happened it somehow brought
in people that knew his identity from
other universes like dr octopus from
spider-man 2. they gotta send these guys
back to where they belong so peter
assembles team spider and track down
sandman and jamie foxx's electro and the
lizard and of course the green goblin
who is norman osborne's evil gollum
alter ego now peter wants to help these
villains because they were all kind of
good guys before their new powers drove
them insane but now the goblin takes
over and doesn't want to be cured and
when ant-may comes to help oh he hits
her with the glider and ant-may dies no
meanwhile ned discovered he can do magic
but he didn't summon his peter that's
the amazing spider-man andrew garfield
and yes they're all coming back it's
toby mcguire too it's hilarious as all
three peter parkers become new best
friends and we get a triple spider-man
finale working together they cure all
these villains and doctor strange is
ready to send them all home but wait the
green goblin pumpkin bombs the spell
which boom it's gonna flood this
universe with infinite spider-man
villains the only way to stop it is not
just to make the world forget peter
parker is spider-man but to make them
forget peter parker at all so it's
tragic as peter says farewell to his
best friend ned and his girlfriend mj
and the spell works everyone sent back
to their home universes and everyone's
forgotten all about peter and when he
sees his friends living happy normal
lives he figures they're better without
spider-man so peter parker goes off on
his own no more fancy stark tech just
your good old-fashioned friendly
neighborhood spider-man last thing you
might want to know from doctor strange 1
remember mordo dr strange's wizard
friend who was mad at him at the end of
the movie for misusing the rules magic
and also it might come up but wong is
technically strange's boss now the
sorcerer supreme cause strange was
blipped away for five years and there
you have it now you're ready for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]